Hello, my name is Adam, and I'll be your assistant instructor
for Introduction to Statistics.
Welcome to our first problem set covering visualization.
Let's get started.
First, I'd like to ask you about a scatterplot,
specifically about the relationship between GPAs
or grade point averages in high school and college.
GPAs are a measure of academic performance
and range from 0 being the worst to
4 being the best,
so let's look at some simulated data
that might describe such a relationship.
A student who received the highest GPA in both,
a 4 and a 4, would be right about here.
And let's fill in the rest of the points.
So looking at this relationship,
I would like you to tell me whether the relationship
between high school and college
GPAs is linear
and whether it is exact.
Check all that apply.